the last campaign by israel has been an
utter failure and you could even say
that they lost
yes they lost this particular offense
the so-called offensive
it backfired in them in the most
dramatic way possible
why because then you could have crushed
them you couldn't crush the palestinians
what was your objectives you only now
say post
at the event that oh the objectives was
to do xyz no the objective was to try
and crush
the resistance and you couldn't do that
even though they're a small band of
people
you couldn't even do that so no you did
not achieve your objectives
now your tourism is going to plummet
because no one wants to go to a place
where there's still volatile
uh volatility like this where some guy
can blow himself up or some missile can
drop on your head you don't
know what's gonna happen no one wants to
go to a place like that who's gonna go
to tourism for that
so you've destroyed that uh stream of
income now you have a lot of money to
pay
yeah because you've destroyed your own
infrastructure with this war
and you've destroyed other people's
infrastructure in fact
in fact when you're dropping bombs and
you know there's a 30
chance it's going to hit a child and a
50 chance is going to hit a woman or a
child
and probably a 90 chance is going to hit
a woman or a child or an elderly
person and you destroy you kill
over 200 people in less than two weeks
using the most sophisticated technology
you kill them and you don't even have
the dignity and the self-respect
to reimburse those families the families
that the people you killed
why don't you ask about them and say you
know what who are you so we can
reimburse we can help you out in life
those buildings that you smashed broken
down why don't you try and get money for
raise money for that and try and what's
that got to do with your struggle
so is that really if you if you really
want us to believe
that you're not going against civilians
and you're not trying to kill them and
actually target them the why is it the
case
that you've left them stranded in the
way that they're stranded you haven't
even offered
monetary compensation you bastards
you are bastards and you have destroyed
your image in front of the
international community and you know
what else you've done you've brought the
muslims together not just the
palestinians believe me the palestinians
were
separated in in ideology maybe or some
political ideas
but now you've actually brought them
together because when they realize
who the real oppressor is who the real
monster is
who the real goliath is they come
together
and so too the muslims have come
together and so too the muslims will
come together
because it's in our apo apocalyptic
texts
that in fact at the end of days there
will be a mahdi a man who brings us
to victory and the center stage will
actually be baital makthis in fact
the saved sect will be allah make this
they'll be on the periphery of that
british
because we know we know how weak you are
and in fact the quran even tells us this
not all jews by the way of course not
jews i'm not talking about jews we're
talking about you
oppressive zionists
and the quran says jews and christians
are all the same
but having said that the quran also
states that there will be some of them
that one of them wishes that they can
live for a thousand years
for a thousand years and they won't even
be able to do
avert the punishment if even they
live for that long
you value your life and the
the mark of someone who won't take risks
and will be limited and scared
and cowardly is that they have nothing
to die for
and the truth of the matter is let's be
honest you people have nothing to die
for
as we have seen with the palestinian
people that their resolve is so strong
that life and death for them are the
same
and in fact death is the beginning death
is the beginning how do you defeat such
an enemy
you can't and that is the reason why you
have failed
and it's a tragedy that their civilians
have died from your side as well
but let's be honest you value probably
one
of your civilians more than one million
of the civilians that have been killed
in palestine even if it's a child
because you are racists imperialists
colonialists all the bad things that
anyone can say about you
bastards can be said and should be said
about you
absolutely because you don't believe in
all children are the same and all races
are the same let's be honest you don't
believe in that stuff
and so that is in fact in many ways your
weakness
it's your weakness because you you were
shocked
about what happened you were shocked
that
it didn't take an intifada in order for
you to
to have casualties and so on you have
you were shocked that there were some
going to be some
uprisings from within uh the west bank
you were shocked at all of those things
and you know what else you were shocked
about
you were shocked about the fact that
those people
who you killed their families those
young and innocent
children that they
their families and the people around the
world
you moved all the people around the
not only to tears but to action
you have completely failed
and you will completely fail some
scholars say
when the verse says
this is some scholars say this is
talking about israel
because when did when did israel have
many israel when did they have uh
ownership over the art
when did they have let off when did they
have this corruptive
ability mother attained two times the
second time
actually there's going to be an enemy
that you're going to have that's going
to take you out of the place which is
not even yours which is
east jerusalem
[Music]
yes
so this is the situation you have
everything to fear
and everything to lose and this is the
reality
you're no longer developing a developed
country you've now put yourself back
uh 20 or 30 years you put yourself back
and you've lost you've lost the
credibility in the international
community lost money
lost lives it's because of your
arrogance
and so the gazans do have a lot to
celebrate today
and in fact not only do they celebrate
we as the muslims will celebrate as well
and we're happy that you had to
compromise and succumb to some
weakness because you are weak
and we are i hope i believe
that all the muslims are watching me
today and all even those who are
probably
just fair-minded people not even muslims
hope that i see the day
where we liberate east jerusalem fully
from your oppressive and occupying rule
and that we
go into the masjid as we went into it
the first time in the quran states
and then you will know what time it is
allah